*claps*
Meme review
meme review
*claps some more*
Meme review.
Welcome everybody to my brand new show called...
Meme Review.
You guessed it
this is a completely original idea that no one has ever done before.
And uh, therefore I am proud to copyright this idea so that no one else can do what I am doing.
meme review©
I will take down anyone with copy STRIKES
I have lawyers
BEWARE!
or else I will be very
A N G E R E Y
On this very first meme review
its--this is a historic moment of this channel,
we're going to pick a meme, somewhat recent.
Maybe you've seen it a week ago, it was a webcomic and it goes like this...
My bike got stolen recently.
Sad face.
But I think whoever stole it was probably more happy to get it than I am sad to lose it
The total happiness in the world increased.
So whatever.
Now despite being the most retarded sense of logic I've ever heard
it's an innocent little webcomic.
But boi oh boi, did the internet not take this well.
People immediately started to parody this way of thinking.
Uh, and uh some of the responses are very funny.
Sonic got killed recently.
I was pretty bummed about it
but I think whoever killed him was probably more happy to see him die
than I am sad to lose him.
The total happiness in the world is increased
So whatever.
As long as total happiness in the world is increased
Whatever.
Amirite?!
We also have,
My bike got stolen recently.
I was pretty bummed out about it.
But then I thought...
*breath in*
WHERE'S MY FUCKIN BIKE?!!
these are pretty innocent parodies
Owlturd even, uh, retweeted them himself.
But then there's uh... *giggles*
then there's uh...the..the more...
DANK ONES?!
*AIR HORNS*
My wife got fucked recently
I was pretty bummed about it
but I think whoever fucked her
was probably more happy to get it on
than I am sad to get cucked.
The total happiness in the world is increased.
*laughs*
*breathes in*
Uh, after this amazing way of thinking sort of spread around the internet
this comic strip got renamed to "Bike Cuck".
The creator of the meme reached out and said
"Please stop calling me Bike Cuck."
and their response *laughs* was
"I guess he just doesn't appreciate that the joy others experience
in perpetuating the bike cuck meme
is greater than the joy he would have experienced it not being called bike cuck."
*laughs at turnaround*
*Inhales really sharply/implodes lung*
As can happen with the internet and things going viral it can be a bit overwhelming...
and, uh, Shen even said that he's gonna take a break because of "personal stuff"
and then of course people made...
My favorite artist stopped-- *laughs*
My, favorite artist stopped posting recently,
I was pretty bummed out, about it but i think whoever bullied--
*laughs*
*laughs some more*
uh..was...
Okay
Alright
but I think whoever bullied him into it was probably more happy to do it than I am sad to lose him
The total happiness in the world increased
so whatever.
Conclusion
of this meme.
I really enjoy Owlturd's work
some of them are really really funny
uhhhhhh
When I was looking around
he's, he's a great artist
no doubt about it
And he even said himself he's okay with the memes
and the reason he took a break was because...
Uhhhhmmm
"Other personal issues"
that somehow appeared at the exact same time
So you know he's embracing the joke
and which is always appreciated
it never looks good if you don't, at least.
But and even some of the responses that I saw underneath his tweet
Literally if you go to the--the tweeting question
the first response is
"This precise bullshit is why hedonism is exactly trash.
Any society based on your bullshit concept would collapse
I'm not saying you should be more upset.
I'm saying that the reason you aren't means that you don't understand utility or deontology.
Learn."
"And while I'm at it...
*epic music*
*laughs*
It's like Jesus Christ, dude.
At the end of the day it's just a webcomic
"And while I'm at it...
how regular, and high an income do you have
to write something like this...
oh my god
I understand him taking a break
and...
At the end of the day
Wh--wh--who, who am I or anyone else
to tell them how to feel
about something happening, you know?
Although the whole letting go something
I-I sort of understand that in the sense of
when I donate stuff
that I maybe have a personal attachment to
maybe uh...
some sweater that I don't really like anymore
but it has some sort of sentimental value
*ring*
And my door is ringing
goddammit...
*Edgar barking at door in background*
*answering the door*
Hello?
*elevator music*
*door opens*
*burps*
But this is not the first time, web comics have been criticized
there's the.. famous
Buzzfeed, web comic Books of Adam which
which uh
Some would say not me of course i love, Books of Adam, it's my favorite web comic of all time some
Some would say
not me of course I love "Books of Adam"
it's my favorite web comic of all time
some would say it's a bit lazy
I mean I don't see it
I see attention and detail into every single strip
and, uhhh, I definitely don't see
Reuploading the same webcomic
two years later
which i have never done with my videos
*laughs*
*wheezes*
But, my favorite webcomic meme of all time
will claim
Is this
if--if you know, this meme you know, what this means
if you don't know, what this means...
it's hella confusing
what about this meme
does this ring a bell?
this is the same meme
it is this one
now I had--I had seen this meme for a long time
and I didn't really get it and
it's a sort of meme that you need to know the backstory of to get
so in case you have-don't know the backstory
don't worry
I'm going to spend the next ten minutes
explaining it to you *laughs*
because there's nothing inherently funny about this, uh, comic strip
itself
but at the same time
it is
*laughs*
Now this, uh, comic strip is from
"Ctrl+Alt+Del" which you, may have heard of before
uh, it sort of came from, ah,
the renaissance
of webcomics back in 2008
the, the four-by-four kind of comic strip
was popularized
and it was about, uh, two guys sitting on a couch
playing video games
very
hilarious
but surprisingly
"Ctrl+Alt+Del" was very popular
it did really well
for its time
and uh, it sort of worked that Tim--Tim would add himself
into the cartoon in the best way possible i would say
"My name is Tim Buckley.
I'm a 24 year old gamer
I've played every violent game in existence
and I have never killed anyone
*music intensifies*
There are millions of gamers just like, me and we're getting sick of people like you blaming your problem on us
There are millions of gamers just like me,
and we're getting sick of people like you
blaming your problem on us!
Ignorance causes violence not videogames man up and take responsibility
not video games
man up and take responsibility
We outnumber you
We outnumber you and the people that think like, you don't fuck with us
and the people that think like you
don't
don't fuck with us
fuck with us."
*garbles* "don't fuck with us"
Despite being very popular
"Ctrl+Alt+Del", uh, it sort of
became more and more criticized over time for lacking
how to tell a joke properly
which is ironic of me to talk about
but
Tim would often blow out the punch line
Before the end of the strip
and uh sort of beating the joke itself to death
and it became a meme to remove the middle strip
and somehow his comic strip, would be then funnier
"All ready to go?"
"I don't know..."
You haven't told me where it is that we are going."
*car accelerates*
"Aaaand...Done, finally."
"...When did we get a bowling ball?!"
*laughs*
"Ctrl+Alt+Del", was also criticized for having
way too much unnecessary
text
now where have
we heard that before
a webcomic with too much text
I can't possibly think of anything
oh, uh, ohhhh, ohhhh
Oh
now the year sort of went by between uh
between
slightly sexist jokes
and uhm
slightly racist jokes
again, ironic for me to talk about
Out of nowhere
comes this comic strip
titled "Loss"
and it sort of hit people
uh
for being so blatantly out of nowhere
that it sort of became the joke itself
no one was expecting this
and the 4x4 panel of comics
is
typically used to make a setup
and then the last strip being the punchline
and now the last
strip being the punchline
of a miscarriage
*breathes in*
oh my god
*laughs*
Which, again
really displays Tim's inability
to properly, tell the story
now don't get me wrong
the miscarriage here is not the joke
the joke is that
The edits of this
make fun of how completely misplaced it is
and the way that Tim handled the subject matter
*troubled, deep, and heartfelt sigh*
In such a terrible, terrible way
that the joke itself became an inside joke
and boi, oh boi
did it spawn up some of the greatest
meme creations I have ever seen
*laughs*
ugmmmm
It's just the some of the most obscure shit I've ever seen
And people really appreciate
The minimalism out of this meme
that you can really reduce it down to just a few lines
and it's equally, emotionally
captivating
as the original
how
how is this possibly--
oh I see it
*laughs*
even the
fucking kanji
can be interpreted
as a lost meme
is that a loss meme
I think it is.
Even in Dark Souls,
someone made the meme inside Dark Souls
someone say that the CAD meme
or lost meme it's the perfect meme
perhaps the greatest meme of all time
it's universal, it's adaptable, and it turns the joke
against its creator
it's a beautiful meme
and of course
There is this
*laughs*
so now you know, about the loss meme *laughs*
god dammit
*wheezes*
Do you get it?!
*laughs*
I would rate the bike cuck meme an solid
8/10
I'm not--I'm not
And i'm gonna have to stick it to the lost meme
for a 10 out of 10
This has been episode 1 of meme review
Thank you for leaving your likes
one like means the world to me
*staring intensifies*
Thank you guys so much for watching
and as always
squad fam o-out
the last thing you see when you die
Pewdiepie, more like Behind The Meme, jk love u